as the game continues gone is a bit
injured but fired up the ball will
remain on gone's side but since the ball
hit the ceiling which is part of the
floor gone is technically out he is
forced to use back to be able to return
to the game
gore enu and kalua pass the ball to each
other until gone is done getting patched
up gorangu who wants to get even with
razer launches a throw directly to his
black ape and switches places with the
ape to hit razer in the face
before it lands on the ground razer's
devil manages to catch the ball and
quickly attacks guarano he is hit in the
face himself and becomes unconscious
gorilla now out of the game for good
says guerra realizes his team is now at
a clear disadvantage
razer's next attack is a slide throw
towards kilua but before it reaches him
the ball changes its direction towards
biscuit and hisoka the two managed to
dodge the ball but one of razer's devils
appears outside beside hisoka and
catches it throwing the ball back to
hisoka hisoka manages to block the
attack using his bungee gum but in spite
of this he stills gets injured
everyone is shocked biscuits out since
her dress was hit and is counted as part
of the body gone uses his back and
returns to the game
kisoka discovers that the ball thrown
outside was less powerful than razer's
attack and killua states that if they
avoid razer's attack they will avoid
serious damage gon disagrees wanting to
win fairly and won't settle for a cheat
win
he wants to utterly destroy razer at his
own game
he asks kilua to stand at the center of
the field and go and charges his men
ability while killua holds the ball for
going to punch
with an incredible force gome lets loose
jjenkin and hits one of razer's powerful
devils sending it out in the field gon
is upset because the attack needed more
power to take down razer before he
attacks again gone closes his eyes and
takes a deep breath focusing his ren he
suddenly releases an immense amount of
aura and charges his men more powerful
than the last time he punches the ball
towards razer while at the same time
razer increases his men to block the
attack using both hands and sends the
ball flying upwards without hitting the
ceiling everyone is amazed at what they
just saw and can barely move
razer explains that they can do more
than catch and dodge while razer waits
for the ball to come down hisoka takes
the opportunity to catch the ball using
bungee gum to send razor out and force
him to use his back
sasgera's group likes their odds three
on two but cesguera explains that their
team is the one that's disadvantaged
seeing the condition of gon and hisoka
to make matters worse killua has
severely injured his hands by putting
only a little nun protection on them to
avoid decreasing the power of gone's
attack tesgera decides to call a timeout
and ask going to punch the ball outside
for him to hold the ball because of his
concerns with kilua's injury kiluet
disagrees and thinks this will be a
cop-out he fakes the severity of his
injuries stating he is fine but biscuit
pulls out his hands from his pockets and
reveals they are very swollen
kiluah insists on holding the ball and
gone trusts his friend and wants kiluah
to hold it for him believing he's the
only one who can do it when the timeout
is over biscuit takes the ball and
throws it to the last devil inside
sending him out of the game
now razer gains control of the ball and
gone comes up with an idea to be able to
stop razor's attack razer drove his aura
and dispersed back to himself to be able
to make a throw with his true strength
razer focuses his aura and threw the
ball to the air for him spiking the ball
towards gon killua and hisoka at the
other side hisoka conceals it in kilua
to support the two from out-balancing
themselves once the balls land in gone's
hands the three succeeded to stop the
ball as razer praised them for what they
have done specifically kiluah as he
points out the role of the three by
stopping his own attack
while razer is planning and preparing to
stop the ball gone on the other hand
releases a large amount of aura where
his teammates are amazed by him and
razer realizes that gone's first attempt
wasn't his full strength and seeing him
going all out he states that he is
jing's son
something jing needs to be proud of
as gon goes all out he punches the ball
straight to razor as razer being aware
of how strong gone's throw was he's
having thoughts even the ball as
catch-able razor wouldn't risk catching
it as due to the amount of power of the
ball he will get out of bounds and
dodging it isn't an option razer tries
the first attempt he did when he stops
going's first throw by letting the ball
hit his forearm but instead of hitting
it in the air he directly hits it
towards gone
says garrosh screams asking gone to
dodge it but razer is convinced that
gone will not dodge it based on his
observation of him however the ball
passes through gohan since he fainted by
using that huge amount of aura to which
says guerra mentions much by his relief
but suddenly hisoka uses his bungee gum
to stop razor's counter and not let
gone's hard work go to waste by getting
a decisive win
hisoka throws the ball back to razer and
as the ball is covered by his bungee gum
when razer tries to throw it back to
them again the ball sticks in his
forearm and he was pushed outside the
boundaries while holding the ball
the ref announces that razer is out and
gone's team is victorious half of the
game gon finally is conscious and
realizes it was hisoka who was the one
that saved the game razer went through
gone and accepts his defeat while
biscuit takes care of kilua's hands and
the others wait razer and gohan have a
conversation razer tells gom then that
jing is not in greed island nor he knows
his whereabouts but he tells some
stories about his past with jing and on
how jing changed him
after speaking to razer gohan and his
team left razor place and an event with
a plot of beach npc takes place in order
for them to obtain the card called plot
of beach
after the event gone and his team
finally got the card following hisoka's
departure kiluah realizes that hisoka
lie for he knows about playing greed
island before meeting them as the group
has a conversation with one another
gentry contacts them demanding that they
hand over the card plot of beach card to
him and threatens says guerra to come
alone
as he continues to talk he mentions the
names of the first group of 15 where
gone first came to razor's place as gon
and the others find out that gentry
killed all of them then gone challenges
genthru but genthru tells him he will go
to him after he is done with says guerra
since go and have another card that he
wants
keluwa asks says guerra to move
somewhere else to avoid gone getting
tangled with genthru yan through and his
gang discuss their targets believing
that it's necessary to hunt sesgera
first and when he surrendered gon will
follow and if they go it gone first it
will let cesguera have enough time to
escape
it is clear that genthru wants the
original copy of the plot of beach and
believing cesguera has it tasgera and
his group will help bone prepare and
heal to battle genthru and his gang by
giving them enough time provoking
genthru's gang and in the middle of
discussion a deal has been made says
guerra states that buying gone's time is
an alliance instead it was a deal to
obtain the card wild luck alexandrite
and will go in at least three weeks of
preparation to plan out how to beat
genthru and his gang
tis guerra's team left to face gentry
while gon and kilua start to heal and
train with biscuit
hasoka and finks meet with the phantom
troop hisoka approaches machi and
nobunaga who are spying on the exorcist
he also notices the newest member of the
troop meanwhile after a short discussion
says guerra's group confronts the
bombers they cast a levy spell on them
and immediately use a company to get
away
after checking their lost cards gemful
feels that says guerra will ambush them
until they run out of cards tezgara
collects some escape teleportation cards
with the help of gorineu gone trains
hard in order to fight genthru biscuit
advises gon to start training in a
mission in order to gain a new weapon in
his fight with genthru while gone is
struggling with his emission training
kiluah and biscuit chat about gone's
power
kiluah asked biscuit to reveal her
technique in order for him to plan
better in their upcoming battle against
the bombers biscuit shows kiluah her
technique called magical esthetician and
it underwhelms killua
says guerra continues to target
genthru's group by sneak attacking them
during the night denfer believes they
have some nem user with the ability to
track them and thinks he knows what
cesguera is planning they start
harassing other players and steal their
accompany and see rank cards they also
check if the other players have already
met cesguera and his group
if not they tell them who they are and
threaten them by making the players
collect cards by force if the player has
met sisguerra's group they dispose of
them gorineu continues to spy on
genthru's group and contacts tesgera to
report their scheme
while gon trains kalua and biscuit
continue to set up a plan
emperor collects plenty of spell cards
in order to pursue sisgera's group
knowing gentry's movements says guerra
immediately casts a spell card to escape
them while gentry casts his spell card
to follow the two groups continue to
pursue and escape each other until
genthru is thrown off by sisgera's group
this gives tesgera and his group time to
think of a plan by using the spell card
return when they run out of accompany
cards gorai new informs says guerra he's
right to think the barra and sub with
genthru are fakes the real sub and bara
are in front of a shop in masadora and
are keeping their eye on everyone
entering the shop says guerra would like
to stick to the plan instead of fighting
gemthru even if he is alone meanwhile
talua informs gohn to stop his training
since he came up with a plan to defeat
genthru and his team
after says gary uses their last
accompany card they plan on leaving the
game and go all the way to battery's
castle if the bombers follow them they
will just fend them off outside the
mansion
arriving at batter's castle the team is
shocked at what they see the castle is
empty and a man named sabazushi informs
them that everyone already left says
guerra who wants an explanation
approaches batara who is locked in his
room with tears flowing from his eyes
genthru and his group arrive at the
mansion and kill sabazushi gorain
contacts gohan biscuit and kalua to
inform them that cesguera's team left
greed island according to their plan
says guerra's team cards will disappear
if they're out of the game for more than
240 hours however he left all the
valuable cards to gorainu
believes genthru will know they have
allies when none of the four hold any
valuable cards
gentry and his team awaits sasgera and
his team at the starting point as they
do not show up before the deadline they
officially celebrate tis guerra's
departure from greed island believing
they never returned out of fear of them
meanwhile gorinu explains that he and
sisgera's team switched 32 of their 96
cards with fakes and gorino holds all 96
real cards he tells killua and the
others that he'll give them the cards
once they've defeated genthru gorainu
warns gone's group when the bombers head
towards masadora to prepare for battle
the three are ready when gohan succeeds
in his training by calculating exactly
one minute in batter's castle sasgera is
curious about a girl's picture on a
table batter reveals that she was his
lover and after an accident put her in a
coma he heard of greed island and
started buying copies to hire players to
finish the game
he needed a player to collect a card
called angel's breath that could
completely heal her however after her
passing all of it has now become
pointless
after planning the bombers go straight
to gone's group and genthru immediately
proposes a deal during the conversation
biscuit and the two deceived them so
gentry's team can't tell they're ready
to fight as well killua keeps refusing
genthru's proposal until gentry loses
his patience killulah gon and biscuit
immediately act and use a company to get
away from them
after using their last accompany gone's
group heads towards masadora and hides
their auras
gentrus searches the whole area but
can't find them so they decide to use a
company straight to gon's group they
don't move meaning gone's group is still
there and it is also the last a company
genthru's group has
after another discussion everything is
going according to the plan by making
andrew's team battle them one-on-one
kiluah and biscuit run away from where
gon is in order to separate the bombers
gon and genthru's fight starts and go
and anticipates his attack making gentry
wonder who told him his abilities gone
doesn't answer and instead proposes a
deal to get through that whoever
surrenders first will give up all his
cards gentry won't bite until gone
swears he would rather die than be a
thief and genthru has no choice but to
agree
gon keeps attacking while remembering
biscuit's advice in the middle of his
fight he might not be as strong as
gentry but he's fast and clever gentry's
hit sends gone flying and gentry
mockingly states that he won't use his
ability on him
gon remembers biscuit's advice that all
is according to plan by letting anthro
calculate how strong he is but gone
being a prideful one plans on making
gentry use his ability against him and
carry on the plan afterwards meanwhile
biscuit uses a company in order to
separate bara from the others and
frighten one on one
barra asks her why she used a company on
him and biscuit replies that she is
stronger than him and doesn't want him
to be helped by the others
she releases a flurry of attacks but
bera says she's weak he's able to send
biscuit rolling on the ground causing
her to transform into a scary muscular
form that killua later takes to call in
the gorilla and knocks out barra in one
punch
he asks why she hit her power and she
tells him she hates that form before he
goes unconscious
at the same time killua battles sub and
kilua reveals his new yoyo technique in
the middle of the fight it weighs 50
kilograms and is easily able to destroy
a tree
sub dodges the best he can but is hit he
notices kilua leaving his right open and
takes advantage by kicking kilua on his
right side
however kilowatt reveals another yo-yo
on his right arm and smashes sub on the
back of the head
he left his right side purposefully open
to trick sub
kilowatt hits him again and uses
electricity knocking him out for good
gone takes a lot of punches from gentry
but never accepts defeat genford
realizes his stubbornness and takes back
what he said he decides to use his
ability to mess with gone's mind and
make him admit defeat
gunfire takes hold of gone's wrists and
tries to blow his hand up by using
little flower but the boy is able to
protect his hand and receives only a few
burns and angers and through yemfer
attacks again grabbing gone's wrist yet
again gon tries the same thing by
putting aura in his hand but genthru
anticipates it and hits gome with a
punch in the abdomen that sends him down
in pain as genthru analyzes what gone is
trying to do by protecting his arm from
his bomb
gone opens a part of his body that is
vulnerable as gon state's biscuit is
right about gentry as the fight
continues after gentry grabs gone he
punches gone again on the body but gone
didn't even flinch this time as he
escapes from him go manages to counter
gentry's last attack by remembering what
biscuit told him about his ability
little flower where you can tell it if
anthro is preparing to use it he shrouds
his aura around his hand and when he is
planning to attack him somewhere else
then he won't use gyo but genthru
immediately sees through this and warns
gone that his plan will backfire and
states the consequences when getting hit
by his little flower denver thinks that
it is meaningless to fight and wants
going to surrender
at the same time while looking at
gentry's arms with both hands wrapped
with aura biscuit words pop in his mind
telling him that if those two hands were
shrouded by aura he will use little
flower and this is where gone should
start sticking to the plan
but go massage on his own and thought of
a plan that he'd like to give it a try
and got back at genthru asking him to
surrender instead gentry walks towards
gone and threatens by telling what he
will do to him and go and invites him as
genthru grabs both gone's arms and uses
his ability to blow up both of his hands
but genthru felt something and realizes
he was hit and got his mouth busted
as genthru is stunned and can't control
his body gone starts to charges jenkin
and launches his attack but genthru
accidentally saves himself by getting
tripped down by a stone realizing that
he was saved gentry analyzes what gon
did by completely not protecting his
left hand and using only a small amount
of aura in his right hand but putting a
large percent of aura in his feet to be
able to land a hit to him this is where
gentry realizes how crazy gone is much
to the extent where gon tells him that
he's done being selfish and it's time
for him to get serious gong opens up his
book takes a card and tells that gentry
needs to surrender or he will die
after gentry had his chance he hits gone
in the throat followed by chop from his
back of his neck which gome blocks using
his geo immediately to card gone is
holding triggers containing a bottle of
gasoline and breaks it towards genthru
even though they can't use his little
flower genther brags about another
technique called countdown which is much
stronger than little flower and it's
impossible to block it livgio as genthu
walks towards gone and sets his
technique and suddenly uses his jenkin
but instead of hitting directly to
gentry he punches the ground that
creates pitfall sending the both of them
deep down to the pit benford thinks
about his situation when he looks to go
and he is nowhere to be found but slits
right through a small path of hole and a
card in his hand triggers that contains
a large rock that will crash again
through but before he gets hit to the
falling rock he managed to save himself
by going to the hole where gone is but
gone waiting for him uses his jenkin and
crashes gentry even if he's surrendering
with the bombers caught they surrender
their cards and by using the card
angel's breath bones injuries were
healed gorania reaches gone but
disapproves on healing genthru of the
others since they were murderers but
later on he can't do nothing about it
after gon killua and biscuit tell their
reasons after healing genthru when the
three is about to leave gorineu stops
and tells them they'll give all the
cards anyway before they even try to
heal genthru since it was a decision
made by him and says guerra and his team
including their share of payments from
batara gohan kalua and biscuit completed
the cards from 1 to 99 and only number
zeros left and a quiz will be held
according to the announcements that each
player in greed island went directly to
gomes group and surround them
gon kilua and biscuit are surrounded by
other game players
because of team goan's success they try
to strike a deal in order to get some of
the game completion reward
gohan and killua agree to a proposal
offered by another game player
if they win the final card team gome
will buy off them for five percent of
the total winnings not knowing about
battery's situation the quiz soon begins
and everyone takes part the first
question being what is the name of the
elder who gives an important hint about
number one patch of forest a hira b hida
c he so
is already struggling with the first
question
meanwhile with the bombers all tied up a
bengain touches gen through and says i
caught the bomber releasing the
netability little flower that was placed
on him
quiz continues and soon the final
question is revealed the player with the
best score is announced
gone wins getting 87 out of 100
questions correct
and al delivers a letter to gome in the
card number 110 rulers invitation
unfortunately gone is only allowed to
enter by himself
suddenly two players gashabellum and
zetsbellum use an accompanying to
confront gon they both threatened to
take his cards by force but are defeated
in a flash gone originally planned to
use an accompanying card to transport to
the castle kilauea however points out
that it won't work as they haven't
visited limeiro before
biscuit suggests using the card number
1016 drift this allows a player to
transport to a previously unvisited city
kilauea uses drift and then returns
shortly after allowing him to use a
company a bengain uses magnetic force to
travel to hizoka using chrome name he
states that he will return to reality
and make a fortune exercising nenov
nanofrollo biscuit in kilowatt weight
outside while gone enters the castle he
is then greeted by list list introduces
him to dwan
when he gets in the room however is
covered in garbage and junk
one makes a space for gonna sit down and
then presents him with the last card
number zero zero zero ruler's blessing
he teases god a little about his father
one gives gon a three slot card holder
and explains the rules of how he can use
it and what cards he can't take list and
one then explain the concept of greed
island's name and how each letter
corresponds to a game master with the g
in greed belonging to jing the one
explains how his name actually begins
with w instead of d
jing changed it so it would work better
with the naming of the game if one
becomes angry at the memory while list
just laughs at him dome likes seeing
jing's old friends
the players and npc of the game
celebrate with fireworks and parades
since the game is now over
team goan enjoys a feast and then decide
which three cards to take back to the
real world kilauea suggests choosing one
each and biski is quick to pick hers
number 81 blue planet killua and gone
devise a plan as only restricted card
slots are allowed to be taken out of the
game meaning spells cannot in the end
the three cards gone selected were a
plot of beach blue planet and paladin's
necklace upon getting out of the game
biski uses gain on her blue planet she
marvels at the gem and loves it right
away first gohan gains his paladin's
necklace then using the necklace
transforms the plot of beech to revert
into an accompany card
dome says he noticed a player's name on
his book and because he was the first
player to enter the game he must have
met this person previously he guesses
that when he was a baby he came to greet
island with jing gom and kilauea say
goodbye to biscuit and then use a
company to travel to [ __ ] the name listed
they appear in a foggy forest-like place
and see a figure sitting at the base of
a tree and fishing
the two boys look on in amazement hoping
that they have found jing at last